là j'étais un peu stressée pour jouer là
ce soir parce qu'en fait les autres
humoristes qui ont joué ici ils m'ont
dit ah tu vas voir à Lille c'est
vraiment un public de connard
ou moi j'ai dis je dis non mais c'est
pas possible c'est des gens qui ont
choisi de de venir voir mon spectacle
donc c'est pas possible ça peut pas être
des connards ils m'ont dit non mais tu
sais làdans il y a aussi des gens qui
viennent pour accompagner des amis ou
pour faire plaisir à leurs conjoints ou
parce qu'on leur a offert les
places
alors je veux savoir comment juste à
m'enlever ce soir quelles sont les
personnes qui ont réservé vraiment
d'elles-mêm pour venir voir ce
spectacle d'accord ça fait quand même
une belle proportion de
connards